[Music]  what is it you like to talk about  my patient  hi  i know you're nervous i just want to  have a chat  i'm seeing something no one else can see  except for me  it's smiling at me  yesterday a patient in your care died  brutally in front of you  [Music]  i need to find an explanation for what  happened  it's smiling at me  smiling at me  [Music]  [Music]  you're going to die you're going to die  you're  i found 20 cases involving 19 victims of  the direct line linking them all  together  [Applause]  you said only 19  why is it that everybody else who's seen  it is dead in your life  i've seen it too  how long between each victim's death  none of them survived longer than a week  today is my fourth day i am not gonna  keep running  i have to face it  how does it make you feel  [Music]  i'm just really scared that something  bad is going to happen  rose  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you